romain miguet journaliste spécialiste de
l'amérique latine fondateur également du
site francophone d'actualité et
d'amérique latine les deux rives point
info bonsoir mon dieu merci d'être avec
nous on va essayer de comprendre ce qui
se passe au venezuela
pourquoi le système kovacs n'a pas à
livrer les doses achetées
alors c'est une histoire qui traîne
c'est le les l'interview là que vous
venez de passer de nicolás maduro
en fait c'est une histoire un peu plus
longues n'ont depuis le mois d'avril le
venezuela donc qui je le répète sous
blocus financier des états unis a eu
toutes les peines du monde mais a
réalisé plus de 12 transactions pour un
montant de 110 millions de dollars des
u11 d'ailleurs à communiquer de kovacs
le 13 avril 2021 qui soulignait que
l'alliance mondiale pour les vaccins et
l'immunisation avait bien reçu la
totalité des 109,9 millions de dollars
et qu'il manquait encore 15 millions de
dollars qui avaient été bloqués par la
banque suisse ubs donc en raison des
sanctions imposées par les états unis
alors visiblement ces fonds auraient été
débloquées toujours est il que le
venezuela n'a pas reçu de vaccin
malgré le fait qu'ils ont débloqué
qu'ils ont payé 120 millions de dollars
donc d'où l'interrogation de nicolás
maduro si vous n'êtes pas en mesure de
nous les livre et rendez-nous l'argent
et alors est ce que l'argent va être
rendue après oui c'est il ya tout allait
évidemment il ya un problème aussi
juridique puisque jeu comme gelée
soulignait tout à l'heure le venezuela
est sous blocus financière le plus
criminel imposé par les états unis et
leurs alliés
il semblerait tout de même que
le lot et metz devrait être en capacité
de réaliser des transactions financières
avec le venezuela puisque il y a eu lie
a par le passé en tout cas les deux
dernières années il ya eu des accords
entre l'organisation panaméricaine de la
santé donc la branche de l'om est pour
l'amérique latine et le venezuela pour
réaliser différents types de
transactions notamment poro pour l'achat
de vaccins alors pas forcément le coc
vide mais pour l'achat de vaccins
courant pour pouvoir vacciner les
enfants notamment venezuela donc on
espère un ne pas forcément pour le
venezuela juste pour le droit
international
on espère que cet argent sera rendu et
on espère surtout que les vaccins
pourront arriver au venezuela et que le
venezuela pourra compter sur les 5
millions de vaccins qu'ils ont commandés
à kovacs et qui viendront en
complémentarité des vaccins russes
chinois et cubains qui sont du lycée
aujourd'hui pour vacciner les manèges le
lien alors selon les déclarations de
nicholas maduro ans les états unis
auraient bloqué un paiement de 10
millions de dollars au système cobas
pour quelles raisons alors c'est on va
dire c'est une une conséquence du blocus
financier c'est-à-dire que les
transactions financières avec l'état
vénézuélien sont interdits de manière
unilatérale par le gouvernement des
états unis et les entreprises
financières ou commerciales qui
réalisent des transactions avec le
gouvernement vénézuélien pasty
médiatement dans la liste du département
du trésor des états unis donc son
elle-même placée sous sanction et je
pense que c'est pour cela que la banque
suisse ubs a congelé tout cas pendant un
temps un peu plus de 10 millions de
dollars qui était destiné à aller sur le
compte de l' oms pour le
l'achat des vaccins alors c'est très
bien d'ailleurs que cette histoire
explose sur fond de vaccination qu'ovide
parce que c'est ce blocus financier
et bien c'est une des principales causes
de la crise économique qui s'abat sur le
peuple vénézuélien depuis maintenant six
ans alors malgré toutes les promesses un
des pays occidentaux pour le moment on
peut clairement dire que ce système est
un échec d'autres pays n'ont pas reçu
ses livraisons prévues alors à ma
connaissance et en dehors de l'afrique
que je ne connais moins j'ai écouté
l'interview que vous venez de passer en
amérique latine même si c'est au
compte-gouttes le venezuela reste le
seul pays hormis cuba évidemment mais
cuba cuba développe son propre vaccin
le venezuela reste le seul pays où les
vaccins ont été niés par par kovacs donc
nous verrons dans les prochaines dans
les prochains jours le dénouement de
cette affaire ainsi le venezuela peut
récupérer soit sans argent ou soit
récupéré les vaccins qui l'a tout de
même payés le venezuela revol a veillé à
rome un minus à ceux fournis et on l'a
entendue dans le sujet a également avec
le vexin russe pout nick v le chinois
sinopharm à et le cubain abdallah est ce
qu'il a réellement besoin de ce
dispositif
kovacs pour vacciner sa population
écoutez il se trouve que c'est on parle
là de 5 millions de doses donc ce n'est
pas rien non plus 1 2 qui viennent
s'ajouter donc aux 12 millions de doses
du vaccin abdallah
mais le mc saïda a besoin de trois
injections donc les 12 millions de doses
concernerait 4 million de personnes plus
les vaccins spoutnik 5 comme vous venez
de mentionner et les vaccins chinois
je pense que dans la lutte contre le
lobby de 19
le gouvernement vénézuélien essaie
d'être le plus large possible pour
arriver à ces objectifs qui est de
vacciner 70 % de sa population à la fin
de l'année et donc on leur souhaite bien
évidemment de rentrer dans ses objectifs
avec toutes les aides possibles et
inimaginables à un niveau multilatéral
merci beaucoup romain miguet d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france merci
à vous